monsieur le premier ministre j'ai le
coeur gros aujourd'hui comme tous les
policiers qui pleure marie biskupski
présidente de la mobilisation des
policiers en colère maggie s'est suicidé
hier quelques jours après un gendarme
chez vous à matignon lui même après un
policier de la paf ça n'arrête pas
malgré toutes les mesures de prévention
des risques psychosociaux ça n'arrête
pas parce que les raisons sont beaucoup
plus profondes et que le gouvernement
n'a pas voulu les voir ces raisons
anciennes ou récentes
notre commission denquête les a décrites
et analysés nous avons fait des
propositions concrètes et réalistes
32 vous avez refusé de les considérer
même de nous en donner acte ici en
séance le 5 juillet dernier n'esquive et
plus ne répondait plus à la marge quand
le problème est au fond policiers
gendarmes passé les deux tiers de leur
temps aux tâches procédurale ils
prennent toujours plus de risques
et au bout du compte pour rien sans
réponses pénales adaptées
il se pose la question du sens de leur
mission et du sens de leur vie
maggie était venu le 7 février dernier
ici au sénat avec son goal son collègue
guillaume lebon nous expliquer cette
réalité sincère franche courageuse
généreuse lucide mais tellement déçue
elle gardait pourtant la foi en sa
mission et un sens du devoir
intact nous l'avions écouter avec
gravité vous ne l'avez pas écoutés mais
vous l'avez fait entendre par l'igpn
pour atteinte à l'image de la police
monsieur le premier ministre
allez vous écouter comprendre des
policiers allez vous entendre à titre
posthume le cri de détresse de maggie
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes de l'intérieur monsieur
christophe castaner merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
grosdidier l'interpeller sur cet
événement tragique de la mort d'une
femme d'une femme gardienne la paix la
mort d'une femme engagée engagés pour
défendre la cause des policiers
je nous invite je nous invite à attendre
le résultat de l'enquêté qui a été
engagée pour connaître les raisons de
son geste
mais au delà des commentaires qu'il
pourrait y avoir su raisons de son geste
vous m'interrogez sur le mal-être dans
la police ce mal être il est réel et je
ne vous opposerait pas des chiffres
notamment sur les suicides des policiers
qui sont cette année en forte baisse par
rapport à l'année précédente il y a
cette réalité cette réalité de ma lettre
que nous connaissons j'étais avec
laurent nyonnaise il y a quelques jours
à viry châtillon à cet endroit d'où cet
endroit est partie justement ce cri de
colère qu'elle a su incarner parce
qu'elle voulait défendre les forces de
police j'étais sur place et j'ai pu
constater ce qui était un acte de guerre
une quinzaine de jeunes ont attaqué deux
véhicules de la police ont tenté de les
enfermer dans le véhicule en lançant des
cocktails molotov ont tenté de les
empêcher de sortir pour les faire mourir
brûlé vif mais j'ai vu aussi d'abord
vincent une des victimes qui se
reconstruit difficilement lentement
j'veux les rencontrer mais qui m'a parlé
de la reconquête nécessaire du
territoire j'ai vu aussi avec laurent de
neste l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre
qui étaient présents sur site qui sont
venus très vite porter secours qui ont
mené une enquête remarquable et
aujourd'hui 13 des jeunes responsables
présumés sont en prison j'ai vu aussi la
réalité avec deux maires de mer de
couleur politique très différentes qui
sont pour lui une ici pour l'autre là
qui ont parlé qui ont porté faure cette
reconquête républicaine de ce quartier
parce qu'en deux ans des moyens ont été
mis sur place une centaine de policiers
avaient été immédiatement dépêchées par
monsieur 15,9 pour justement ne laisser
aucun espace avec la république qui
recule ce que je sais monsieur le
sénateur c'est qu'il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui de renforcer ses moyens avec
un budget qui augmente de plus de 1
milliard d'euros en deux ans avec 300
millions d'euros investis dans
l'immobilier avec un niveau d'équipement
véhicules comme
mais vu mais aussi monsieur le sénateur
avec des propositions de réforme de la
procédure pénale telle que madame la
ministre vous a présenté la semaine
dernière qui permettent justement
d'éviter que les policiers passent trop
de temps dans cette procédure et soit
sur le terrain parce que c'est leur
demande
j'ai vu aussi monsieur le sénateur les
choix politiques qui ont été faits dans
cette assemblée
[Applaudissements]